there are good reasons you see so many
people with Latin tattoos for a start
Latin is a highly economical language
you can say a lot and just a handful of
words another reason is that Latin
literature is full of timeless tourism
observations made over 2,000 years ago
are often as applicable to us now as
they were to the Romans
here are five quotes from Latin authors
I feel are just as relevant to us today
number one known word Amos Mantic I
wouldn't air go west we cannot see the
baggage there's on our own back in the
mid 1st century BC the Latin love poet
alice observed a common human trait or
we find it really easy to recognize
faults and other people we tend to be
more or less blind to our own each of us
has been assigned his own fault he wrote
but we cannot see the baggage that's on
our own back catalysis message Stanton
from over 2,000 years ago is to think
about your own faults for criticizing
others to omnia wink at em all love
conquers all love in Virgil's line isn't
just a human emotion if the divine force
love and more is Cupid the son of Venus
the goddess of love he will strike you
with his arrow and make you fall
hopelessly in love the love stick poet
he sighed omnia wink at amor neither to
be in love isn't necessarily to be happy
being love is also to be in pain
Virgil shows us there's no point in
trying to fight it omnia wink at a mall
at Nostradamus and Maury continues
you're better off yielding to love than
trying to shield yourself from his spell
three
the Horton and bibliotheca habits they
areand me here if you have a garden and
a library your lack nothing sister
actually wrote if you have a garden in
the library your lack nothing
houses in Rome typically heard the
garden in the middle of the house rather
than at the back in the ancient world
there was a tradition for learning
outside students at Plato's Academy in
Greece for instance used to learn among
the trees
Cicero's message is if you have books in
nature you have everything for in Reno
Veritas and wine is truth anyone who's
drunk a few glasses can vouch this wine
loosens the tongue it may make you talk
a lot of nonsense but as the ancients
knew it could also make useful your
secrets the historian Pliny the Elder
alluded to a popular saying about wine
bringing out the truth where it is we
know asked at the same time he pity the
drunks he do not see the Sun rising and
therefore live shorter lives five
Donette eros sauce phase macho slimmer
artists amico for as long as you're
doing well you'll have many friends
operators one of the leading poets of
his day but fell foul of the emperor and
was banished to the coasts of modern
Romanian well there he wrote about his
miserable fate which he blamed on a poem
and a mistake the poem was full of
advice about how to love and make love
and was far too raunchy for his times
what the mistake was remains a mystery
to this day in exile the once popular
poet found himself friendless the
message is surely to work out who your
real friends are before it's too late
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon